hi guys hi guys hello YouTube just love
us in our friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
10th episode of dirty chess tricks again
Sicilian in this episode I'm going to
show you some of the high profile tricks
in the closest Ilyn from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following water that is e 4 C 5 and now
white continues with the move Knight to
c3 the main line of the closest rien
goes as follows Knight to c6 g3 g6
Bishop to g2 Bishop to g7 D 3 D 6 and
Here I am going to concentrate on the 2
moves that is Bishop to e3 and Knight to
h3
first of all let's consider the
absolutely main line which continued
from here onwards Bishop to e3 e6 Queen
to d2 and now here black has two good
choices
probably Knight G to e7 is a more
accurate choice but the most popular
choice from here is rook to b8 and after
the theoretical move Knight to f3 Black
has tried this most popular choice
Knight to d4 and surprisingly enough
this is what the theory suggests and if
you check this position in online
database even you will find out that
night to d4 has been played highest in
this position but can you believe this
move is a big time blunder yes indeed
and the modern engine confirms this with
a pretty accurate sequence so this is a
big time trick you should remember if
you are playing close Sicilian and even
if you are not playing close to Cillian
in the tournament if you find out that
your opponent is following this main
line then you should certainly give a
shot to finish him quickly
the repetition goes as follows Bishop
captures d4 here it doesn't matter that
whether you open and take with the
bishop or the pawn if you take with the
bishop the night capsules d4 and the
same line will be goes so the most
accurate response here is pawn captures
d4 afterwards white will continue with
the move Knight to b5 so attacking two
spots so black responses force black has
to play Queen to b6 to defend both the
threat and now white keep pressurizing
the d6 square with Queen to b4 again
black responses force black has to play
King to d7 because if we continue with
the move Bishop to f8 then after the
following continuation that is Queen
captures d4 Queen captures d4 and Knight
captures d4 not only every single black
pcs are at this original position
but on top of everything black is a
clear pond down so this is straight away
of winning advantage for the white okay
so the force reply is king to d7 and now
White has this amazing shot in this
position that is e Phi so the renewing
threat of capturing the d6 pawn and this
position is not easy to play as a black
for example the only accurate response
here is D captures ePHI but after the
Moon Knight to d2 just on the 13th move
of the game black has completely lost
position I got this position against a
2100 rated player in online rapid game
where my opponent continued with the MU
a 5
now instead of a fuh if you open and
continue here with the MU a 6 then this
is a big-time disaster because after
Knight to c4 attacking the Queen Queen
catches B file and after Queen to d6
check King to e8 and Queen captures b8
not only white emerge with an extra
exchange but still black is going to
face a long-term difficulties the first
obvious threat here is Knight to d6
snapping the Queen and it doesn't matter
whether black moves the Queen or moves
the King let's say as for the engine the
most accurate response is Queen to c5
defending the c8 but now comes Knight to
b6 and that is a monster night because
not only is attacking the c8 but it is
also looking at the epsilon square and
on top of everything black has a check
to face so the obvious response is king
to d7 afterwards
Knight to f7 Knapp's another row and
exchange and in fact again
so considering all this disaster in the
game
my opponent continued with the move a
PHY attacking my queen I responded with
Queen to e4 so trying to get a
Discoverer attack my opponent responded
with king to d8 the beauty about this
position is black king is stuck in the
center so that gives all the fun to the
white camp and to illustrate my point
how quickly white get winning position
let's see few moves Knight to c4
attacking the Queen Queen to e6 Queen to
e3 so black doesn't have time to capture
this 9 because after Queen check black
is going to lose the rook in the corner
so in the game my opponent decided to
continue with the move Bishop to d7
blocking the check and attacking denied
I responded with Knight B to D 6 so
looking at the EPS 7 for the folk so my
opponent defended with night to at 6
but after Knight captures ePHI so there
is x-ray on Queen with Knight checked
and then having the Queen so my opponent
defended with rook to e8 but after
Knight captures b7 check King to c7
Queen to C Phi check came to b8 and
castle on the King side I think this is
a hopeless position for the black as
many white pieces are surrounding on the
black King and black camp is completely
miss coordinated you can check out the
rest of the game in the PGN which is
available in the description
the second trick I'm about to show you
is very effective against a player who
plays Botvinnik system against closed
Sicilian so against Botvinnik structure
my recommendation is why it should
continue with the move Knight to h3 and
the black opening more order goes as
follows
'if i castle on the King side Knight G
to e7 and now the standard move f4 once
again we reach to a very critical
position where I think the most accurate
choice for the black is to play Knight
to d4 but as happen in this many closest
in annoyance theory are not accurate and
once again if you check the online
database you will find out that in this
position the most frequent choice from
the black is to click castle on the
Kings side which is again leads to some
very much tricky play by the white so
let's see what's wrong with this natural
looking move castle on the Kings side
well after that white has this amazing
move fi if black doesn't take this pawn
then after g4 white attack will roll
down on the King side so the obvious
move need to be considered what happens
if black except of a pawn sacrifice G
captures fi pawn captures f5 and now
here black has two choices how to
capture their fire pole amongst them
Knight captures fr is a worst of all
because after the following sequence
that is Queen to h5 attacking the knight
Knight to d4 defending as well as
attacking on c2 Bishop to b4 once again
hitting the night
so black responses force black has to
defend this Knight and the most natural
way to defend this is to play Queen to
f6 and now white simply increase the
pressure with
Knight to d5 attacking the Queen Queen
to g6 and the star mu in this position
is Queen to d1 this position has so many
threats from the website the first
obvious threat is Knight to e7 and
nabbing the Queen as this night is
completely pin if rook to e8 then white
can even consider the moonlight to c7
and nabbing the exchange and the third
problem that let's say if black defend
the e7 square with the move Bishop to f6
then there comes c3 destroying the one
of the defender of the FI night Knight
to c6 and now the very simple Queen to
f3 and there is no way black is going to
save the piece and in fact the game so
considering this option Bishop captures
fr is the most accurate choice by the
black and at first sight it looks like
black has won upon for nothing but here
comes the nasty idea by white and that
is fool ha ha ha
so sacrificing the whole exchange just
within 11 moves of the game
okay black response is force Knight
captures fi and now if you check out
this position right now White has a
bishop for Rupe and a pawn which is
obviously not a good trade but why it's
big idea is straight away going for the
King side attack with the move Bishop to
e4 now this night is attack and
accordingly there are four good choices
from the black if either of the noid
comes to the d4
let's say 9f captures b4 then the
simplest is you continue with the move
Queen to h5 attacking the born FI
defending on at 7 but after the
following continuation that is Bishop
check King to h8 and Knight to g5 I
think there is no stopping one at 7
if at 6 then Queen to g6
and at seven is still threatened with
the maid and if black picked this night
then after Queen check blacking is going
to be checkmate in two moves Bishop at
six and queen at six is a mate the
second move if the sea Knight goes to
the d4 then scenario will won't change
because after Queen to h5 if Queen to d7
then g4 is a very strong reply so
accordingly the most nature looking move
is Queen to f6 guarding on fi but we
already know from the previous video
that whenever the Queen f6 happen then
we can instantly play Knight to d5
attacking the Queen and after Queen to
g6 and Queen to d1 the same problem as
we see on the night cups of FI black is
going to lose a piece a sample line can
run like this Bishop f6 c3 Knight to e6
and now g4 and that night is going to be
lost if black defend with Knight e to g7
then after King to h1 I'm painting the
g4 pawn and in fact winning the whole
piece so it is very obvious here that if
black tried to hold on to that night
then he get the lost position in the
opening so there are two good way black
and respond in this position among them
the number one is night to h4 so trying
to give a piece back we're white pawn
structure will be completely destroyed
but of course we are not going to take
with the G pawn in this position but
rather White will continue with the move
Queen to h5 so attacking the s7
attacking the knight so black responses
force black has to play Knight to g6
defending both the threat but now comes
Bishop to defy so idea is once again to
play Knight to g5 and hitting on at 7 so
black needs to stop all this with a
knight C to e7 but after the following
sequence that is Knight to g5 at 6 and
now Knight G to e4
I think black position is not a pretty
sight I got this position against a 2008
opponent where my opponent continued
with the moon came to at 7:00 I
responded with Bishop to d2 so my simple
idea is join as many as pieces in the
attack and create some nasty problems in
the black camp my opponent responded
here with a nightcap is defy I take the
night and now he played the moon Fi
which i think is a somewhat inaccurate
because after night check King to g8 and
night to e6 it is already a very hard
position to play as a black not only his
g6 Knight is attack but white is [ __ ]
Queen and hook in the game after some
thinking
my opponent continued with Quinn to e8
defending the knight but after the
following sequence that is Knight
catches g7 King captures g7 Bishop to at
6 King to g8 Bishop captures f8 black
has to forcefully captured with the King
but the sting in the tail
after few checks let's say Queen check
King f7 Queen at 7 check King f8 and the
final blow Knight to c7 and white wins
the piece in a broad daylight last but
not least what happens if you open and
continue with the move Knight captures
g3 well here why doesn't have any choice
White has to take this piece and now
blacks idea is to continue with the move
f5 and arguing that White has a weak
King on the g1
compared to his black ink well it's not
the case here because after Bishop to g2
white get two minor pieces for a rook
and to pawn and in this situation is
specifically very good now to illustrate
the danger in this position in the black
camp I like to show you one of my rapid
game against a title player where my
opponent continued with the move Queen
to e8 so his idea is to immediately
concentrate on
King site no matter I continue with the
move Knight to d5 looking at the c7 he
played Queen to g6 attacking on g3 I
responded with Bishop to g5 and after x6
and Bishop to h4 he just double up on
the F file with group two EPs Evan okay
white continue with the move c3 so
stopping any knight intrusion my
opponent indeed develop with the move
rook to f8 and now very strong new king
questo and it's very funny here that
even though black has some aggressive
looking piece looking on the Kings side
in fact it turns out that black is in a
complete zoogs rank this Knight cannot
move because Knight to e7 will happen
none of the major pieces are going
anywhere and the most important feature
in this position is black doesn't have
any pawn breaks of walking and on top of
everything one has a simple thread that
is Bishop to f3 and Bishop to h4 and
whenever this happens black position
will be completely collapsing here my
opponent responded with King to achieve
I played the obvious move Bishop to f3
and now the Queen goes on a very funny
square Queen 27 ok Bishop to h5 happens
anyways he continued with the rook to d7
but after Queen to f3 it is very clear
that it is only white one has a good
initiative here my opponent desperately
want to open up the game so he continued
with the movie 4 but after 22 Knight to
e5 pawn captures pawn captures and the
move Knight H to f4 Black is in a very
difficult situation
he tried c4 to get some counter play but
after Knight to e7 after long thought my
opponent decided to resign as night g6
is coming with some deadly threat and he
is about to lose his eforp own with a
completely lost position
well I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful high profile tricks in the
close Sicilian from the white
perspective you feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care